yeah as to be expected intense weather
causes major delays here at harry reid
international airport as we're near and
also people travelers very irritated as
many were left having to find a place to
stay for an extra night because of it
they switched our flight to 6 30 without
letting us know
that our flight changed to 6 30 in the
morning monday morning and our flight
was scheduled to fly out at 7 40 p.m
tonight khan pove visiting from seattle
like so many other travelers sunday
afternoon left in vegas for another
night that because of the intense wind
and rain the valley has received the
last couple of days and while
residential areas and businesses are
still reeling from the aftermath
travelers at harry reid international
now feeling the effects as well it's
cancelled didn't know it was canceled
till we got here got in line to check in
and they said it was canceled so
spending the night flying out tomorrow i
think we're just going to stay here for
the next nine hours until we can
board a united flight which is
kind of unfortunate because i'm trying
to get back to work like i already took
tomorrow off i don't really need to take
tuesday off within the last hour delays
have gone down significantly earlier
there was close to 250 delays with 45
cancellations at harry reid
international airport
as for those dropping off passengers
during the day be prepared for potential
weight at the southwest airlines ticket
counter
as construction crews have begun
installing more steel post ballards in
front of the area causing some delays
and as for the airline with the most
delays and cancellations you know it was
truly all across the board many
travelers also hearing that it was a
shortage of staff as to the reason why
there were so many delays today
reporting near the airport madison
kimbrough live local now